we'd have to touch it because it's a big
part of your your past yeah and and your
story and you know one that you've uh
exploited as of late yes big time you
were sick when you were little yes yeah
not little you were I was a teenager
yeah when I was 15 I was diagnosed with
childhood leukemia and I had treatment
and well this will bring up another
story with my brother I had treatment
until I was like a like 17. so like for
a couple years which is the standard
like treatment for that and there's a
chemo radiation yeah I had chemo and I
had like 10 days of radiation
um and yeah so it was a difficult time
but I
um I really my family was very
supportive Jonah was always really
supportive and
um and I don't mean to skip ahead like
past this but it really made me think of
a Funny Story which is that please do
this so I was done with treatment like
the summer before my senior year of high
school and I had an end of chemo party
that's kind of how I was doing it okay
like I was like I'm not hiding from the
attention that this illness gives me
yeah you know always loved attention and
I'm gonna obviously have a party to
celebrate my end of chemo of course yeah
so my brother and his friends like I had
I had people over to my parents house
and my brother and his friends like
played I got my brother to play like
music in the backyard and I thought it
was so cool because Jonah and his
friends were like performing in the
backyard and then there was like a noise
thing where like one of the neighbors
called the cops or something like that
and so the the police came over and they
thought we were having like an underage
drinking party which it's like hey guys
it's an end of chemo party and once you
figure that out you're gonna feel like
really big so they were like
going through and then my parents were
and we were like it's an end of chemo
party and the cops I think felt
they're just doing their job but like I
think they felt really bad because it
was like why don't you go deal with the
real criminals okay yeah yeah whoever
called this in yeah why don't you go
arrest them for being bogus yeah but
it's just so funny because thinking back
on my brother at that time so like if I
was a senior or I was almost a senior in
in high school and my brother was like
almost a sophomore I guess in college
like he they were probably just playing
like crazy like it probably wasn't even
probably just a mess yeah from the
neighbor's house it just sounded like
base feedback yeah exactly like and I
was like this is awesome I want
everybody to hear this like all my
friends from high school are gonna think
I'm awesome yeah like yeah yeah what
waste of your life did your life change
I mean yeah from having that like in the
middle of high school you're kind of
yeah sold out of totally you're sort of
sidelined from things in a lot of ways
um I think that it made me
um it it's sort of yeah it's sort of
side line me in certain ways and I think
in some ways it made it once I went to
college and stuff and was on my own I
really felt like I was playing catch up
a lot and stuff
um but in other ways I think it sort of
made me it sort of like was the
beginning of my like comedy career
because I realized that with my friends
if I would joke with them a lot they
would feel comfortable around me and
they would feel like I was the same
Vanessa and everything and my parents
and my brother like would always be
joking about it like we would joke a lot
about
um like this special treatment that we
got which is sort of
um has is has sort of made its way into
my show I love that for you because it's
like just just the way we would get
treated and
um and even the doctor's appointments
and sort of just the way I don't know it
just there was something there was sort
of like we found humor in all of it and
it really like I just remember joking
about it with my friends and just it
felt so nice to be able to do that and I
think it like I think because that was
such a powerful thing when I was sick it
sort of was later when I realized I
wanted to do comedy I think that I don't
think I knew it at the time but I think
that had a lot to do with it because I
was like this is such a like healing
thing and it's such a great like sort of
common language for everyone to speak
when you're going through something so
hard yeah I always think it's fighting
back yeah it's fighting back it's like
you know an enemy not to be corny but
yeah there's a lot of Darkness so it's
like hey I'm gonna make some light you
know light meaning two different things
like you know getting rid of the
darkness but also hey come on yeah yeah
and
you know sometimes it's whistling past
the graveyard yeah yeah but a lot of
times it just seems like no this is what
this is what needs to happen yeah like
that totally do you feel like
do you think you'd be in the same place
if you hadn't been sick I don't know
have you thought about that I have I've
I've been like would I what would I have
done would I have I mean there's like
it's something interesting because when
I was a little kid I was always like
putting on shows and Performing and
stuff like that but then when I was like
in middle school and high school I was
kind of like Shire I wasn't doing that
stuff as much I think yeah in my
experience around well that's gonna
sound terrible no having a teenage
daughter yeah there comes a point I was
about to say my experience around
teenage girls which I just meant her and
her friends yes yeah
um is there just seemed to become a day
with all of them whether they were like
I don't want anyone looking at me yeah
stop looking at me world yeah you know
and so I think that's you know yeah so I
think I think that's true like because
you just want to be the same as
everybody else and you don't want to
really stand out and so I think I wonder
in some ways I'm thinking through as I
say it like in some ways I guess because
I was sick I didn't have the choice like
I kind of had to stand out and I maybe
reminded me that I actually loved that
attention and I love you know but I also
I yeah it was such a helpful thing when
I was sick I don't know I really don't
know I truly I remember being in eighth
grade which was like a year before I was
diagnosed and taking
um and taking a career quiz we all had
to take a career quiz and
um I think the career I got was
newscaster oh yeah so I think I I was
interested in performing still but was I
don't know I really don't know but not
about the real world no I I I yeah I
think the the career test was saying
yeah you'll want to perform about
um like yeah a three-car pileup yeah and
you're like nope and I'm like well yeah
yeah I started out in college in
journalism and and realize like I don't
care about other stories like I just
want my stories I don't care about real
things I want fake things that's how
when I went to college I was like I
really was into
um like chemistry and stuff I really
liked science in high school and I
thought I started out as like a biology
major that's how Matt was like my you
had to like put something down and I put
down biology and in my mind I think I
was like I'll be a biology teacher who
or I'd be a biologist who has like her
own show
or like or like I'm like a medical
researcher who's like who's also a
birthday card does
like a does like a her own show about
medical like everything sort of ended
with like me having my own show
so then it was like and then and then I
found it accepted to Harvard Medical
School great I mean that's fine and
everything yeah yeah yeah I gotta get
the show right now but I'll do like a
reality show while I'm in the but I
think that um yeah so then I think Carl
in college I started taking really I
started off with like a really tough
biology class and it was so hard and I
think they were trying to weed out the
not the people who would do pre-med and
stuff yeah and I was like oh I got it I
gotta be a Communications major yeah
that made it sort of clear yeah yeah I
could do that